Générique
...
Musique douce
-Bonjour et bienvenue
dans votre magazine
de l'éducation.
De la sonnerie
aux devoirs,
en passant
par la cantine,
comment sont
les journées de vos enfants ?
Qui sont ceux
qui font l'école ?
Vous allez tout savoir,
grâce à "Liberté,
égalité, scolarité".
Voici, tout de suite,
le sommaire.
Je vous emmène
en voyage autour du monde,
mais depuis le lycée international
de l'est parisien.
A Noisy-le-Grand,
des élèves triés sur le volet
ont choisi les sections arabe,
brésilienne ou chinoise.
Six heures de plus
dans leurs emplois du temps
pour pratiquer les langues
et s'imprégner
de cultures lointaines.
Le goût de la géographie,
elle aussi
l'a eu très jeune,
dans son école de filles,
à Paris.
Evelyne Dhéliat nous dira comment
elle a fait la météo à la télé.
Ce sont ses Mémoires d'école.
Nous mettrons ensuite le cap
sur une cantine idéale :
une cantine bio, locale,
où tout est fait maison.
Il y en a de plus en plus
dans les établissements scolaires.
Dans ce collège de Dordogne,
les élèves se régalent
de l'entrée au dessert.
Et nous terminerons l'émission
avec le sport à l'école.
De la gymnastique virile
à la recherche
de l'épanouissement collectif,
le Réseau Canopé fouille
ses archives
pour un nouveau coup d'oeil
dans le rétroviseur.
Musique légère
...
Depuis la réforme
du baccalauréat,
les lycéens qui aiment
les langues étrangères
peuvent s'inscrire
en section internationale
avec six heures
de cours en plus par semaine
dans une deuxième langue.
Ce dispositif existe
surtout
en lycée international,
sorte de tour de Babel
où se croisent
langues et cultures.
Nous voici donc
au lycée international
de l'est parisien,
situé à Noisy-le-Grand.
Ici, les élèves ont le choix
entre la section brésilienne,
américaine, chinoise.
On commence
par la section arabe
Suivez-moi.
Musique dynamique
...
Ils se saluent en arabe.
-On va prendre la lettre
qu'on a déjà commencée
la dernière fois.
Elle parle arabe.
...
Vous vous rappelez
de ce qu'on a vu
la dernière fois ?
...
-Les timbres ?
-Les timbres.
...
Une carte.
-LE COEUR.
...
-Câlin ?
-Câlin.
On va faire des phrases
avec ces mots.
Elle répète en arabe.
Un élève parle arabe.
Elle répète la phrase
en arabe.
Oh, là, là, Adam...
Ils rient.
Il a dit :
"La douleur dans mon coeur
"est comme le feu."
Musique apaisante
...
-Expliquez-moi
un petit peu :
pourquoi vous avez choisi
cette section ?
-Ma famille est
d'origine algérienne.
Mes grands-parents
parlent pas français.
J'apprends l'arabe
pour parler avec eux.
-Et toi ?
-C'est un peu
les mêmes raisons,
mais c'est aussi
pour le futur.
Pour travailler à Dubaï
ou dans la péninsule arabique,
tout ça.
-Tu te vois bien
travailler en arabe
ou, en tout cas,
ça ferait
une corde de plus
à ton arc.
L'enseignante parle arabe.
Les élèves parlent arabe.
Alors, là, vous apprenez
la langue, la littérature,
mais est-ce que
vous apprenez aussi
la culture du monde arabe ?
-Par exemple, on peut voir
un auteur égyptien
ou libanais.
On a des visions
différentes.
-Dans votre cours,
on ne parle pas français.
Là, vous avez fait
des traductions pour nous.
-C'était vraiment très bizarre
pour moi de le faire.
Je me suis forcée.
-A traduire ?
-Oui, pour vous.
Mais on ne parle
pas du tout français ici.
-Quel profil ont vos élèves ?
-Il y a des élèves
qui viennent des pays arabes,
qui ont eu une scolarité
dans les pays arabes,
qui veulent continuer et valoriser
un peu leur parcours.
-Leur acquis.
-Voilà, leur acquis.
Après, on a des élèves
qui ont fait de l'arabe
depuis la 6e
ou l'école primaire,
il y en a aussi.
Et après, on a une troisième
catégorie d'élèves
qui ont appris
dans des associations
ou à la maison
avec leurs parents.
Ils justifient d'un niveau,
donc on les prend.
Musique dynamique
...
-Bonjour, monsieur le proviseur !
-Bonjour.
-Si je vous dis que les élèves
intégrant votre établissement
passent un concours,
c'est le cas ?
-Oui, c'est exactement ça,
ils passent un concours.
On constate
que nous scolarisons notamment,
mais en grand nombre,
des jeunes issus de familles
qui ont immigré en France
il y a un certain nombre d'années.
Ce sont des enfants issus
de la 2e, ou 3e,
ou 4e génération,
des familles
qui sont bien insérées
et qui sont elles-mêmes
en pleine promotion sociale,
qui veulent le meilleur
pour leurs enfants.
On voit à travers cela,
effectivement,
l'ascenseur social.
-Est-ce à dire que vos élèves
ont un meilleur niveau
que les autres ?
-Par la force des choses,
car ils sont sélectionnés.
Même si nous veillons
à varier les publics
que nous accueillons,
il s'avère que dans certains
quartiers défavorisés,
de Seine-Saint-Denis notamment,
on a pu observer que les familles,
les élèves eux-mêmes,
et parfois leurs enseignants,
ne s'autorisent pas
à postuler sur des parcours
d'excellence comme cela,
s'autocensurent.
Donc l'idée, c'est de briser,
en quelque sorte,
ce déterminisme-là
et d'inciter à la fois
les familles,
les enfants, les jeunes
et leurs enseignants
à oser candidater
au Lycée international.
Et nous en avons tous les ans,
des élèves qui viennent
de ces collèges de REP et REP+,
et on voit leur réussite,
autant que celle des autres,
dans notre lycée.
Musique légère
...
Elle s'exprime en mandarin.
Les élèves répondent.
...
-Tu peux me lire ça, ça et ça ?
-Ca veut dire...
"L'inégalité
entre hommes et femmes."
-Ca ? OK.
Et ça, c'est quoi ?
-C'est la politique
de l'enfant unique, en Chine.
-Vous, vous êtes
une professeure à part,
dans cet établissement :
vous êtes
déléguée par la Chine
pour venir travailler ici.
-Oui.
La Chine s'occupe
de recruter des profs en Chine
pour donner des cours
de littérature ici, en France.
-Le programme
que vous transmettez ici,
que vous appliquez ici,
dans le Lycée international,
il vient d'où ?
Il est créé par qui ?
-Ca vient de l'Education nationale
de France.
Musique douce
-Cette section chinoise,
ça pourra
te servir pour la suite ?
-J'envisage de faire des études
en Chine, si j'arrive
à entrer à l'université.
-Dans quelle université ?
-A Pékin.
-OK.
-C'est vraiment dur,
c'est sélectif.
-Pour étudier quoi ?
-L'économie.
-Vous avez aussi des cours
de... Comment ? DNL, c'est ça ?
-Discipline non linguistique.
-Voilà.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites
comme matières ?
-Des mathématiques en chinois.
C'est différent par rapport
aux autres sections.
Eux font histoire-géo,
mais c'est pour éviter
d'avoir des conflits
avec la Chine,
qui ne voudrait pas avoir
une image détériorée de son pays.
C'est compliqué, les relations
avec la Chine.
La Chine est un peu
un pays... fermé.
-Ouais.
Musique calme
...
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des élèves français ?
-Bonne question.
Une question...
Ca va être une grande question.
J'entends souvent les élèves
qui me disent...
qu'ils sont stressés,
surtout les élèves de terminale,
je trouve,
qu'il y a beaucoup de devoirs,
beaucoup de pression.
Pour moi, franchement, c'est...
J'ai essayé de comprendre,
mais en fait, en Chine,
il y a plus de concurrence,
donc nous avons plus de pression.
En Chine, c'est plus dur.
Musique dynamique
...
-Bonjour !
Ils répondent en portugais.
-Pour aujourd'hui,
on va faire
le débrief de notre voyage.
C'était une première fois
pour moi et ma collègue,
d'aller aux Açores.
Qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ?
Elle s'exprime en portugais.
C'était la première fois,
pour certains d'entre vous,
que vous pratiquiez
le portugais en immersion.
-Ca, ce sont les photos du voyage ?
-Oui.
Musique légère
...
-Vous revenez d'un voyage
aux Açores ?
-Oui.
-Racontez-moi.
Comment ça s'est passé ?
-Ca nous a
fait plein de souvenirs.
C'est aussi ça,
l'école, nous faire des souvenirs
pour qu'on s'en rappelle, plus tard.
On le refera peut-être pas.
...
-Alors, la mobilité, c'est important
pour vous, en tant que professeure
en section brésilienne ?
-C'est évident.
Etre sur place,
c'est effectivement
l'aboutissement
d'un projet de 3 ans.
Ils font tellement d'heures
en langue étrangère
qu'ils voient ça
comme une partie d'eux.
Même les élèves
qui n'ont aucune liaison
avec le monde lusophone,
ils sont tous un peu brésiliens,
ils ont tous cette partie
de "brasilidade", comme on dit,
en eux.
-Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
-"Brasilidade", c'est...
En tant que brésilien,
on dit que c'est
cette joie de vivre
qui est innée chez nous.
On dit que c'est quelque chose
avec lequel on est nés,
qu'on arrive...
-A transmettre ?
-A transmettre.
...
Ils parlent en langue étrangère.
Musique douce
...
-Cette semaine, notre invitée
pensait elle aussi
se spécialiser en langue étrangère.
Elle préparait une licence d'anglais
mais c'est finalement en français
qu'elle présente depuis 1991
les prévisions météo
sur la première chaîne.
Vous l'avez reconnue ?
Evelyne Dhéliat nous raconte
ses meilleurs souvenirs d'école.
Bonjour, Evelyne Dhéliat !
-Bonjour, Valérie !
-Merci beaucoup
de nous accueillir
chez vous, à TF1.
-Avec grand plaisir.
-Expliquez-nous un peu
quel type d'élève vous étiez.
-Curieuse, je m'intéressais
à pas mal de choses...
Parfois un peu dissipée,
c'était marqué...
J'adorais avoir
un peu ma bande.
Il faut dire qu'à mon époque,
c'était pas mixte.
On n'était que les filles.
Donc il y avait
de temps en temps
des petites rivalités,
bien évidemment.
-Vous nous avez ramené
les bulletins ?
Quelques exemplaires.
-Je vous les ai rapportés.
Ca, ce sont des collectors !
-Oui, je vois ça !
Expliquez-nous.
Là, on est en quelle classe ?
-Là, 4e 2.
-4e 2.
-Année 1961 !
-Oh !
-Alors, "Observations",
ça, c'est pour le trimestre :
"Elève appliquée, des progrès
à réaliser en mathématiques
"et en sciences."
En revanche, en récitation,
j'avais 17/20.
Tout ce qui était oral
et tout, déjà,
ça me plaisait beaucoup.
-Plus l'oral.
-Et en géographie...
La géographie !
-Oui, qui vous sert peut-être
encore aujourd'hui.
-J'étais 2e sur 29 !
La géographie, déjà, j'adorais ça.
Et la météo... Bah voilà !
Ca a bien matché avec la météo.
-Alors ensuite,
vous avez poursuivi vos études
à la Sorbonne en anglais.
-Effectivement,
parce que...
Mon rêve, c'était d'avoir un métier
où on a du contact,
donc peut-être de voyager,
de bouger.
C'est pour ça que j'ai commencé
une licence d'anglais,
que j'ai assez rapidement
interrompue.
Pour me faire un peu
d'argent de poche,
à cette époque,
en tant qu'étudiante,
j'ai répondu à une espèce
de petit concours,
enfin une demande de l'ORTF...
-D'accord.
-...à l'époque,
et il fallait
présenter les programmes
en français et en anglais.
J'y avais été au bluff
- je parlais pas très bien anglais,
c'était le début -
et j'avais dit :
"Je fais une licence d'anglais",
et j'avais été...
-Prise ?
-Acceptée.
-Ah, OK !
-Voilà.
C'est pour ça que petit à petit...
-Vous avez complètement
abandonné la licence d'anglais.
-Absolument.
Of course.
Elles rient.
-Je voulais savoir si,
dans votre carrière,
vous avez eu l'occasion
de présenter
votre métier
dans des établissements scolaires ?
-Oui, ah oui.
Oui, ça m'est arrivé souvent.
Une année, on m'a donné
des tout-petits,
donc des CP.
Il y a un petit
qui m'a dit :
"Une fois que tu es montée
"dans tes nuages pour voir le temps
qu'il fait, pour redescendre
"dans ton poste de télévision,
on te met une échelle ?"
-C'est fantastique.
-Il m'avait fait le dessin et tout.
Je lui ai répondu que j'allais
pas vraiment dans les nuages,
mais que c'était des messieurs
qu'on appelle des scientifiques
qui savent ce qui va se passer...
-Qui vous donnent l'information.
-C'est ça.
-Merci beaucoup,
Evelyne Dhéliat.
Musique hip-hop
...
Nous voici
devant le collège Jean Ladignac
à Saint-Cyprien.
Ici, depuis la rentrée,
la cantine est labellisée 100 % bio
et 100 % fait maison.
C'est le 6e collège de Dordogne
à obtenir ces labels.
Nourrir 255 ados
avec de bons produits du coin,
c'est la mission
du chef et son équipe,
et ça commence dès 6h.
Les voilà qui arrivent.
Bonjour.
-BONJOUR.
-C'est vous le chef ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
-Enchantée.
-De même.
-Bonjour, l'équipe.
-J'espère
qu'il va faire meilleur
en cuisine.
-J'espère aussi.
Musique dynamique
...
-C'est parti.
Avant de commencer,
je vous équipe un peu.
-Je vous suis.
-C'est pas très sexy.
-Pas grave.
-En termes d'hygiène,
c'est vraiment réconfortant.
...
-Tac !
Allez, c'est parti.
Aujourd'hui, on a quoi ?
-Aujourd'hui,
on a une petite salade fromagère
avec des copeaux de fromage
ou des carottes râpées au cumin.
Ensuite, on va avoir un poisson,
on va faire une petite croûte
avec de la chapelure,
du beurre, du persil,
et un peu de citron dedans.
En dessert, mousse au chocolat,
classique,
la recette de ma grand-mère,
avec des fruits.
-OK !
Et ceux qui aiment pas le poisson ?
-Ils ont du poisson.
Elle rit.
-D'accord.
-On a réalisé
que plus on mettait de choix
sur la ligne de self,
plus les enfants étaient difficiles,
moins ils goûtaient et ils allaient
vers les choses qu'ils aiment.
Ce qu'ils n'aiment pas
ou ne connaissent pas,
ils n'y vont pas.
Quand il n'y a pas de choix,
c'est comme ça et voilà.
-OK.
C'est quoi, la suite, là ?
-Je vais me mettre
sur les mousses au chocolat.
Musique entraînante
...
-Là, oeufs totalement bios,
certifiés ?
-Ah oui, oui.
On a l'étiquette.
"Ferme de Marcillac".
-Ca ne coûte pas plus cher,
de manger local et bio ?
-Absolument pas,
mais il faut
un peu consommer autrement.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Il faut manger moins de viande,
de meilleure qualité,
un peu moins souvent.
Ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on réduit
un peu les grammages.
Je vous donne un exemple :
avant,
on avait des steaks hachés
qui faisaient 110 ou 120 g.
Maintenant,
on fait des steaks hachés
qui sont à 100 g.
Vous voyez, on enlève 10 g,
c'est rien.
Vous le voyez pas, sur un steak,
et on a l'apport de protéines.
Musique légère
...
-Oh là là !
Sonnerie
Ca a sonné, non ?
-Oui, c'est le boulanger
ou le poissonnier.
On va voir.
-Allez !
-Vous me suivez ?
...
Je vous présente Jérôme,
notre boulanger.
-Bonjour.
-Bonjour !
-Il m'apporte une fournée
de pain cuit
et une fournée de pain précuit,
ça lui évite de faire deux voyages.
On réduit les voyages.
Nous, on le recuit
un petit coup au four,
le précuit, le lendemain,
et ça fait exactement pareil.
Donc, l'impact écologique
est énorme.
Lui, ça lui permet
d'avoir un peu plus de temps.
-Bien sûr.
-Et nous, ça nous permet
d'avoir du pain chaud
un jour sur deux.
-Et ça influe aussi sur le prix
du produit.
-Tout à fait !
Evidemment ! Et vous travaillez
avec des farines bios, j'imagine ?
Ou pas forcément ?
-Uniquement des bios,
de préférence locales.
En trouvant
des organisations comme ça,
les enfants ont du pain frais
tous les jours,
de très grande qualité...
-Et qui coûte pas plus cher.
-Tout à fait.
-Et toi, t'es rémunéré
au juste prix.
-Et moi, je gagne ma vie,
honnêtement.
-Ben bravo.
Bon courage, alors !
Merci, au revoir !
Musique légère
...
-Le département a embauché
une diététicienne qui nous suit
dans l'élaboration
de nos menus.
Vous voyez, on a 4 jours de semaine.
Crudités, viande hachée,
féculents...
Avec au minimum 60 %.
Donc, le reste, c'est en légumes.
Donc, je fais pas les menus
comme je le veux,
ce n'est pas
au gré de mes envies.
Je suis ce plan, et ensuite,
j'intègre mes petites idées,
nos petites envies aussi.
-Qu'est-ce que ça a changé, vous,
à votre façon
de faire votre métier ?
-Ca a redonné du sens
à mon métier,
parce qu'on retravaille
de saison...
Les saisons des légumes,
des fruits,
je les connaissais plus.
Je savais pas qu'il y en avait une
des poissons.
J'avais tout perdu.
J'ai travaillé
dans des macarons Michelin,
dans des étoilés,
et là, arriver à monter un 100 % bio
tout seul avec Fabien, ici,
c'est la plus grande satisfaction
professionnelle de ma carrière.
Ca, on va pas le traiter
aujourd'hui.
Musique légère
...
-Bonjour !
-Merci de nous accueillir
dans votre établissement.
Vous êtes la principale du collège,
la gestionnaire du collège.
Expliquez-moi combien coûte un repas
pour les parents.
-Pour les parents,
un repas coûte 2,99 euros.
Nous avons calculé qu'en moyenne,
un coût journalier coûte 2 euros
en achat de denrées par personne.
-Acheter du bio et du local,
ça coûte 2 euros par repas ?
-Par repas, par personne,
à peu près, pour les denrées.
-OK, et donc le reste,
c'est ce qui permet
le bon fonctionnement
de ce système ?
-Exactement, avec, bien sûr,
des financements du collège
et du département,
qui complètent cette participation.
-Qu'est-ce que ça a changé
à la vie de l'établissement,
de faire du 100 % bio
et 100 % local ?
-C'est ce qu'on appelle
"le climat scolaire".
-Ah !
-En fait,
ça fait partie
d'une dynamique de lien social.
Quand on achète local,
ça veut dire qu'on commence à tisser
des relations avec des partenaires
qui sont sur le territoire.
Le collège change de place,
en fin de compte :
fini l'établissement scolaire
Education nationale,
c'est une entité propre
à son territoire.
Ca va au-delà
du "bien manger, mieux manger".
C'est plutôt "d'où vient
le produit que je mange ?",
"est-ce que je peux le produire
chez moi quand je serai adulte ?",
"où je vais pouvoir me fournir
quand je serai adulte ?"
C'est plus sur une vision,
pour les collégiens,
à long terme
et de futurs citoyens.
Musique légère
...
-Tu vas prendre du poisson ?
T'aimes bien le poisson ?
C'est meilleur qu'à la maison ?
-OH OUI !
-Ah ?
-Ca m'a fait aimer des choses.
-Ca t'a fait aimer des choses ?
Comme quoi ?
-Ben par exemple, le poisson,
c'était pas trop mon truc.
-Parce qu'il est meilleur ici ?
Et parce qu'on t'a proposé
de goûter...
-Il est bien salé, j'aime bien...
Ben c'est parfait.
-OK !
Et surtout, vous donnez votre avis ?
Ca vous arrive ?
-OUI, OUI, OUI !
-C'est vrai ? Et du coup,
le chef change un peu la recette ?
-OUI.
-OK.
Musique douce
...
Ca y est, le service est terminé ?
-C'est terminé, oui.
-Combien de repas ?
-Aujourd'hui, 180 repas.
Je viens de voir les déchets,
on est à peu près à 21 ou 22 g,
en arrondissant, par élève.
-C'est beaucoup ou pas ?
-Non, c'est très, très peu.
La moyenne nationale,
c'est à peu près 120 g,
donc on va dire qu'on est...
-Très en-deçà !
C'est une vraie satisfaction,
pour vous,
un plateau où tout a été mangé ?
C'est la plus belle récompense ?
-Oh, ben oui !
Quand ils disent que c'était bon,
quand ils viennent se resservir...
Sans se jeter de fleurs,
oui, on est très, très contents.
Musique douce
...
-Faire du sport à l'école,
c'est essentiel :
ça améliore la condition physique
tout en transmettant
les valeurs éthiques du sport.
Avant de devenir le cours
d'éducation physique et sportive
de tous les collégiens
et les lycéens,
le sport à l'école a commencé
par de la gymnastique
et uniquement pour les garçons.
C'était en 1880.
Retour en archives
avec le Réseau Canopé.
-En près d'un siècle et demi,
15 tutelles ont pris soin
de l'éducation des corps en France.
15, de quoi faire une équipe
de foot, avec ses remplaçants,
mais les élèves savent-ils
que le but
n'est pas celui
qu'ils croient ?
Voyons cela de plus près.
1880, comme toujours,
c'est Jules qui ouvre le bal.
A contre-courant
des idées de l'époque,
il ose tout :
l'éducation physique
a sa place à l'école,
pour les garçons, bien sûr.
Et en avant
pour la gymnastique !
L'instruction sera virile.
Il s'agit de produire
des corps sains, utiles et forts,
pour augmenter les rendements
dans les usines,
et qui pourront servir la patrie.
Les militaires sont à la manoeuvre.
Années 20.
La guerre de 14-18 achevée,
les militaires ont laissé la place
aux médecins.
Les courants eugénistes ont
le vent en poupe.
L'éducation physique
corrige les maux et les défauts.
Pour ne pas nuire
à la santé des futures mères,
les filles bénéficient
d'un programme adapté.
Au lendemain de 40-45,
les questions d'hygiène et de santé
sont de retour.
"VARF" n'est pas le cri du chien,
mais le credo d'une époque :
vitesse, adresse, résistance
et force.
On cherche l'attitude correcte.
La pratique sportive arrive,
avec les jeux collectifs.
-Vous qui regardez l'émission,
quel est votre jeu préféré ?
-1960, à Rome,
rien ne va plus.
Aux JO, l'équipe de France
rentre bredouille,
pas une médaille d'or.
-C'est la seconde faute !
-De Gaulle et Herzog prennent
le taureau par les cornes :
la France doit produire du champion.
C'est le BTP qui gagne.
Les équipements sportifs
poussent comme des champignons.
Les lois-programmes s'enchaînent
et les communes sont appelées
à participer.
En 1975, l'éducation physique
devient officiellement
l'éducation physique et sportive.
-Il appartient aux pouvoirs publics,
et à eux seuls,
de développer le sport.
-Il en restera toujours une élite.
Il faut s'accoutumer à l'effort,
se dépasser soi-même,
et à défaut de médaille,
on pourra passer l'été
à la piscine municipale.
L'activité sportive permet aussi
de s'épanouir
en dehors de l'école.
L'UNSS et les clubs y contribuent.
A partir des années 80,
l'EPS est enfin reconnue
comme discipline,
une des missions de l'école.
Les années 2000 et 2010
voient le renforcement de la notion
de compétences, d'autonomie,
de socialisation,
en lien avec le projet personnel
de l'élève.
L'accent est mis sur la dimension
inclusive de la discipline.
L'EPS évolue. Le sport est conçu
comme un moyen, non une fin.
On décloisonne : activité physique,
sport et arts
peuvent se tenir la main.
L'EPS est un levier déterminant
dans la formation
d'un citoyen cultivé et lucide.
Marquer un but, gagner le match
et voir son drapeau
sur les écrans de télévision,
le sport a toujours besoin de héros.
Si l'or est une valeur refuge,
l'EPS nous rappelle
que derrière l'appétit de médailles,
il y a aussi d'autres valeurs.
Plus vite, plus fort, plus haut,
prenons rendez-vous
avec Pierre de Coubertin à Paris
pour les JO 2024.
-Et voilà, l'émission
est déjà terminée.
On se retrouve vite
pour un prochain numéro
de "Liberté, égalité, scolarité".
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...